the Joe Rogan experience yeah there was
a few people like way back when I first
started you know things were pretty
lacks when I got in you know they would
get you know urine tested for cocaine
and whatever but some people would go to
Oaxaca and go on mushroom trips like
some of the veteran guys that would go
through whatever there's a there's a
place in Oaxaca and Veracruz where they
go up into the hills and get some of
those but they call them Belarus which
is like basically going to midnight and
they would smoke these mushrooms and
take them and they would come back
apparently fix some of them that was
like the story mm-hmm
it was pretty good for them to work
there's things out well John Hopkins is
there doing Studies on psilocybin and
there's been studies done in psilocybin
with troops with PTSD and then they've
found that that it does help them MDMA
is another one that Maps is doing all
these studies with MDMA and troops
coming back with PTSD yeah I mean a lot
of this stuff has been around for a long
time now there
yeah like women are the beatles and
members of the doors went down there too
yep my the SI Vina
and they found out about it was a life
magazine article from the 1950s that was
one of the first really mainstream James
here if you find who wrote that it was a
life article in the 50s I'm trying to
remember that the guy's name
Wasserman Wasserman I feel like it's
Wasserman who was one of the very first
guys to sort of mainstream psilocybin
mushrooms and it was because of Mexican
tribal cultures maria Savina was like
the the figurehead of that movement she
was a lady that would do these mushroom
trips for people that would come up in
the hillside with her she would take her
was it Gordon Watson ah it was close
yeah it was something like that
Gordon Watson that's right yeah so this
was seeking the magic mushroom and I
believe this was what year was this
cherry I think it's in the 50s I typed
in 1957 okay Maryna left a whole legacy
of that in Mexico and she had a lot of
people that learn from her and a lot of
these people are all over Mexico doing
you know healing and spiritual work
well that's the other thing about Mexico
Mexico has some you have some freedom
like my friend Edie Edie clay he had a
ibogaine retreat down there where people
would go to get off of pills yeah
because it's one of the iboga is one of
the best ways to get off of particularly
opiates yeah
there's you know there's this
enforcement is hard in a country like
Mexico so you're not gonna have people
trying to go inspect things and run
these parts so that's why there's a lot
of places like that you still to this
day you can go to places where Hawkeye
we're technically that's taking
mushrooms is illegal but they go on the
hillsides it didn't they kind of like
decriminalize a lot of different things
down there for personal use so the
quantity is now matter more than they
used to so sometimes you would get
caught with a certain quantity of
something and that means you're selling
it so those how many grams of mushrooms
can you have up but everybody has a
different opinion on what personal use
is I mean I remember the first time I
saw like a bucks a box of them and I'm
like a load of these and you know later
on I figured out what they were and you
know they were a thing they're a thing
in Mexico there's their big thing in
Mexico hmm there's a lot of people grow
them they're a big thing to anyone who
finds out about them to eat them they
become a big thing yeah yeah apparently
I think they use them in rituals and all
sorts of weird rituals down there as a
doorway type element like there's a
there's a ritual where they do with
where they bury you alive in a shallow
grave oh Jesus yeah it's pretty
basically a isolation chamber love
really poor man's isolation chamber they
bury you alive in the shallow grave with
a rope with a bell on it and they give
you a bunch of mushrooms so you can
think about things in there and if you
freak out you ring that bell you know
they dig you out yeah Oh God yeah how
you breathin down there they go to
percents a shallow grave it's just
basically you know about that much dirt
there's a hole where the rub goes
through your so you're gonna fine but
it's a it's a part of the death cult
down there they do that to kind of
initiation people into it but it's it's
mushrooms like they take mushrooms
there's a bunch of weird stuff that goes
there as far as the the the use of
psychotropics like mushrooms and other
things to put people in them and that
mindset of you know accepting a very
specific deity or truth out there mmm
[Applause]